ein heißes massa nie unterschätzt und
vista von mac demnächst ihr erstes kind
plus wieder für mich zurück aber das
muss man das bild der viel zum thema
vergewaltigung hat sehr viele reaktionen
ausgelöst positive reaktionen
aber ein negativer die frau war wohin
offen über die erlaubte sexualisierte
gewalt geräte sind zum teil über
beschimpft und verunglimpft wurde so
heftig dass das online team leider hat
musikalische was mit dem effekte polish
wird über die schlimmste beispiel ob
ähnliche rede märz zusammen mit dem urin
ots sie ist eine von der vier
protagonisten vor dem film unter akuter
von der opferhilfe und beratungsstellen
london
ich tue mir jetzt gerne mal die
kommentare sind zwei vor lassen zum
beispiel hat mich einlasse
man soll sein fleisch nicht in
schaufenster hängen wenn es nicht zum
konsum geeignet ist und tust du es doch
dann sei dir der gefahr durch ein paar
schlecht erzogene triebtäter oder trieb
täterinnen bewusst oder ein weiterer
kommentar
wo ist eigentlich gut ist aber nicht
immer sind nur männer und frauen sollten
autos achtet dass sie nicht noch die wut
zeigen ich long hot pants minirock
durchschnitt das provoziert einfach auch
ständig auch und dann werdet weniger
frauen vergewaltigt großartige ähnlich
wie momentan hat sie gehört was macht
das mit ihnen halt schon länger in
öffentlichkeit und kommt dementsprechend
einigermaßen gut mit medikamenten
umgeben immer auch zweifelhaft weil ich
danke also wohl eigentlich sind 20 20
und wirklich jeder begriffen hat dass
mut zeigen gar nichts und niemandem
tracht gibt
über den von der person verfügen weder
physisch oder auch maintal
es geht sicher kommentare wie die un
würden sie sich persönlich war ein
ziemlich schlechten schlaf zweit oder so
castaño
die einzeln aber was sind das denn dass
das auslöst aus show aber trat so kommen
da wo vor allem manche liebe seele so
operiert das machen wir das sagt doch
irgendwo dass betroffene frauen immer
noch gibt sie mit
warum vergessen dass auch im jahr und
das falsche annahme krise auf die
überzeugung des opfers besuchen wo ist
eigentlich so pathetisch wie so dass man
das macht mein base glauben machen dass
das sicherheitsbedürfnis ist dass sie
machte die illusion aufrechterhalten vor
der heiler welt und basement das ist
sicher sagte wiese sexualisierte viel
mitgemacht verhalten ist hiermit control
mit dominanz mit fehlendem respekt
gegenüber glaube nicht dass man die
gesellschaft leben
das machte aktuell sexualisierte gewalt
problem ganz wichtig es ist nicht
aufgabe ist es aber dann man sieht diese
kommentare lassen sie sagen das macht
sie haben kanal passiert meistens schon
online
danke also wirklich problematisch und
[Musik]
genauso
aber ich weiß das social media sowie
kommen ganz ganz schlimm sieht das nicht
so
und betroffene also welche ungeheure und
wird mit seiner oft nicht realisiert
aber sie eigentlich sagen ich nehme sie
haben sich nämlich auseinandergesetzt so
öffentlich machen dass eine lawine wird
ein heißes massa nie unterschätzt
akvis mit dem namen christi ist das kind
bloß wieder für mich zurück aber das
macht das ja was ich das gefühl haben
muss und da möchte ich jetzt noch mal
auf so kommentare das problem hand ist
das brave sich jetzt auch stark zeigen
und dass man darüber öffentlich darüber
regt um dauerhaft kommentare jetzt
kommen die schreckschrauben aus dem
nichts die einfach gerne mal ein
bisschen im rampenlicht stehen möchten
und ein riesiges geltungsbedürfnis haben
oder ein weiterer kommentar diese
mediale zurschaustellung halte ich kaum
für den richtigen weg und mit der
reaktion muss man dann halt auch umgehen
können warum er so viel mühe damit dass
man jetzt das auf gemacht dass man
darüber rede ich halte das schwierigste
ist haiming also ich glaub du nicht mit
dem konfrontiert war zwei mal klappen
wobei die haie warten im hafen problem
wo man jeden tag damit konfrontiert
weiter und das ist ein risiko oder zu
hornisse und das mit weißen hosen
ansetzen
der vorwurf wenn sie im frühling sind
oder dass man seit märz wenn sich das
wichtigste hafen betreibt braucht oder
sagen naja aber für das thema haben wir
dann eine vorstellung dass mehr
heutzutage sitzen können aber wenn man
sich um seinem ganzen weg zu bringen
andererseits soll das mit verfolgt das
wird mir mit freiberger es ist so absurd
danke das macht aufmerksam für
aufmerksamkeit
für so eine tat im affekt sondern viel
zu verlieren
und eigentlich waschen und sieben für
ihre hätte sie schnitten sondern die
betroffenen sie in die box sie hätten
sich erhofft dass ich vielleicht nur
betroffene frau angesprochen fühlt und
vielleicht pc zeigen sie nachrichten mit
schrecklichen geschichte und ach so ich
lasse mich diesmal alles oder und ich
probiere so ganz auf das sorgt für wiese
und versuchen freundinnen virtuelle
freundin dort sie aber bases das ist
unser problem ist wie schaffen es alle
nachrichten die er bis zum schluss zu
machen
das ist dieses problem ich weiß dass wir
ganz viele schlecht und nicht möglich so
der öffentlich dass sie gar nicht könnte
verkauft
übersetzt ich das rennen machen ganz
vieles nicht richtig steht dass der
betroffene wieder einigermaßen gut geht
ihm besser geht und wenn ja wenn man an
die öffentlichkeit geht
würden sie der frau rothe das betreute
zu machen
grundsätzlich sei sie dann kritisch
ein entscheid aber sicher so dass das
wofür ihn zukommt besitz gehört worden
das ich je nach dem sehr heftig und die
zweifache mit uns grundsätzlich sicher
gut wenn wir uns stützen
ob das ist bei der fachstelle das ist
die freiheit unterstützen professionell
ist das natürlich umso familie und so
ist ja ich stand da war mir die besten
für den aktienmarkt nicht du bist noch
filz verletzt und zu uns gar nicht und
dann ist im august immer wieder moment
kam mit herz machen sie jetzt nach ist
es denn wirklich ändern und so ich mache
da vorbereitet sie was ich natürlich für
michael thonet einfach c oder tod sowie
haut so präsent bewahrte sich natürlich
auch ständig mit dem konfrontiert und
ich habe im vorfeld wären es egal was
sie sagen aus münsingen und wenn man es
mal vorbereitet sie und wissen wenn das
ist dann wirkt ratlos ich spontan ein
taxi oder weniger das öffentlich zu
machen am tag und dann genau kann so
kann sie punkto auch sehr viele positive
kommentare ich immer wieder das wort nur
vor zum beispiel dass solche kommentare
zeigen eben auch wie sehr unsere
gesellschaft ein problem damit hat wenn
frauen und selbstbewusstsein und mut
gewinnen und solche dinge offen
aussprechen oder nur mut spricht es aus
davor haben die täter angst ihr seid so
mutig danke dafür
hartmut bucht in your maker michael
häupl wirklich aus einem zehntägigen
heizt der steuer oder und und selber
mittels etwas auf mich an zu extrem wird
braucht ja
danke an alle wo sich so konstruktiv
komitee street und wir hoffen das bleibt
weiterhin so und wenn ihr genügend für
bosse
dann abonniere doch unseren kanal und
aktivieren